March 25th 1992 was a big day for
Pakistan the national cricket team beat
England to win the world
Imran Khan was the face of victory the
Pakistani captain was already a global
celebrity and he had a reputation for
being a handsome bachelor but almost 30
years later Khan's public identity has
completely changed he is now Pakistan's
new prime minister
So how did
Pakistan's cricket superstar become its
new leader and will he be the one to
bring change in a country that has long
been controlled by its powerful military
Oh
from a young age imran khan was exposed
to foreign influences he grew up in
lahore where he attended british prep
schools and eventually went on to Oxford
University where he sharpened his
cricket skills living in England Khan
started gaining popularity as a
cricketer he embraced his life in the
West and became a staple of celebrity
culture his athletic career lasted more
than two decades after winning the World
Cup in 1992 he retired from the game
initially he stayed away from politics I
am NOT meant to be a politician there
not everyone becomes the prime minister
to help his country in 1994 he opened
the first specialized Cancer Hospital in
Pakistan around the same time he started
shedding his ladies-man image and
re-engaged with religion he married his
first wife of three British heiress
Jemima Goldsmith's
who converted to Islam after they
settled in Pakistan where he further
distanced himself from his life in the
West in 1996 Khan created his own
political party the PTI he promised to
build an Islamic welfare state that
would take care of the poor and hold the
people in power accountable only few
people are held accountable the rest who
unknown crooks get away with it come
back to fight another nation he had a
strong anti-corruption message and
positioned himself as the alternative to
Pakistan's two political dynasties the
sherrif's and the Bhutto's who had been
trading off power and corruption charges
for decades at first Khan's party had
little success failing to win a single
parliamentary seat in the 1997 elections
but several years later in 2013 Khan's
party won control of a northwestern
province bordering Afghanistan his
anti-corruption agenda has started
gaining ground especially among young
Pakistanis and it was working on a
national level he went from being the
longshot to a strong political contender
in the election for prime minister he
lost in a wash to wreath of the Sharif
dynasty but was now a key political
player in Pakistan
as a cricketer Imran Khan was a reliable
performer but as a politician he has
taken some unexpected turns in 2013
Khan's party called for a review of
Pakistan's controversial blasphemy law
which carries a death penalty for
insulting Islam they said religion was
being misused to attain power in the
majority Muslim country now five years
later Khan has been criticized for
defending the same law earlier as part
of his anti-corruption stance Khan
denounced opponents Sharif's party but
later he recruited candidates from the
same party to boost his own Khan has
also been criticized for his leniency
with the Taliban in 2012 after 14 year
old Malala yousufzai was shot in
Pakistan by the Taliban for championing
education for girls Khan showed support
for the militant group at large calling
their fight a justified holy war.
Khan blames the US for the rise of extremism in the region.
He has long been a critic of US
military intervention in Afghanistan
particularly the drone strikes along the
Pakistan border this anti-american
sentiment resonated with large parts of
the Pakistani population that see the
US as an enemy
his own solution for the Taliban is
centered on peace talks a push that has
earned him the nickname Taliban common
so you're basically recommending a
strategy of negotiation with the Taliban
and a complete elimination of the drones
if I hear you properly it is the only
way believe me it is the only way
what makes khan's tolerance of the
Taliban interesting is that it seems to
align with the interest of the Pakistani
military the military's power can be
traced back to 1947 when British India
was divided into two countries a Muslim
majority Pakistan and Hindu majority
India as people migrated to the country
of their religion intense violence broke
out the Pakistani military stepped in to
settle conflict at the border becoming a
symbol of national identity and the
establishment that held a new country
together since then the military has
controlled all national security and
foreign policy matters one of their main
concerns is the war in Afghanistan which
benefits them in two ways on one hand
the US has paid the Pakistani military
billions in exchange for routes to the
country to continue their fight with the
Taliban at the same time the military
supports the Taliban because the
instability in Afghanistan keeps the
country isolated from Pakistan's rivals
especially India
the military has also interfered with
the democratic process within Pakistan
since independence it has either ruled
the country directly or controlled it
indirectly Pakistan has had 22 prime
ministers and none of them has ever
completed a full term
they either resigned they were
terminated they finished a term they
didn't start or they were assassinated
there were also three successful
military coups because of Pakistan's
tense political past the election was
high stakes in the months leading up to
the vote religious extremist groups try
to destabilize the electoral process
by killing at least 200 people in a
string of attacks including a polling
station bombing on Election Day that
killed 31 people just weeks before the
2018 election Khan's opponent former
Prime Minister Sharif was convicted of
corruption and sentenced to 10 years in
jail the military was accused of
engineering Sharif's downfall and
clearing the wafer Khan Khan went on to
win against bilawal Bhutto and Shahbaz
Sharif the new candidates from
Pakistan's political dynasties his win
was followed by protests and accusations
of election fraud which he said he would
investigate and on August 18th
Imran Khan was sworn in as the Prime
Minister of Pakistan since the victory
his corruption message has remained
front and center:
But his anti-american stance seems to be
shifting:
Whether leader will bring about the change he promised is still uncertain the only
certainty is that his leadership will be
shaped by his relationship with
Pakistan's most powerful authority: the
military.